JUST BECAUSE WE ARE IN L.A.,
"THE WIZARD OF OZ."
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
RIGHT LIKE THE MOVIE THE
GODFATHER, "THE WIZARD OF OZ"
PROVIDES LIFE LESSONS AND
PARALLEL TO CURRENT EVENTS.
NOW WATCH AND LISTEN TO
JOE BIDEN CLOSELY.
>> YOU KNOW, THE RAPID RAISING
WITH -- WITH I DON’T KNOW, WE
SHOULD BE FOR EXAMPLE, HAVING A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE IF WE HAVE
THE WHOLE IDEA OF THE THING THAT
THE CONGRESSWOMAN DID.
>> Laura: I NEED TO BUY A
VOWEL.
OKAY?
ASIDE FROM THIS SENTENCE
FRAGMENTS THAT LEAD TO NOWHERE,
AREN’T YOU REMINDED OF THE
WIZARD HIDING BEHIND THAT
CURTAIN, TRYING TO PROJECT A
FIGURE OF STRENGTH TO THE PUBLIC
YET ULTIMATELY FAILING?
LUCKY FOR JOE HIS STAFF LIMITS
HIS INTERVIEW TIME AND THE PRESS
BLOCKS AND TACKLES FOR HIM AS HE
MUTTERS AND STUMBLES ALONG AS
YOU JUST SAW.
NOT ONLY DID COVID TO GIVE BIDEN
COVER FOR LONG FORM INTERVIEWS
AND IN PERSONAL EVENTS, IT ALSO
ALLOWED HIS CAMPAIGN AND
ANTI-TRUMP FORCES TO KEEP
DISTRACTING US WITH FALSE
NARRATIVES, SHINY OBJECTS AND
PERPETUAL FEAR.
LIKE WATCH OUT!
A SECOND WAVE IS COMING!
START SHUTTING EVERYTHING DOWN
AGAIN!
OR THE COVID ECONOMY WILL NEVER,
EVER RECOVER!
TRUMP RALLY ATTENDEES WILL BE
SUPER-SPREADER’S.
THEY ARE ALL SELFISH.
THEY ARE RECKLESS.
THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
AND TRUMP DOESN’T CARE ABOUT
PEOPLE’S HEALTH.
REMEMBER A WEEK EARLIER, IT WAS
MY WOW THOSE MASSIVE BLM PROTEST
ARE INSPIRING.
TRUMP WILL REFUSE TO LEAVE
OFFICE IF HE LOSES.
AND OF COURSE THE DISTRACTION OF
THE STATUES AND THE FIGHT OVER
ALL THAT MARBLE.
NOW, THE NEW GENERALS OF A
THEOCRACY BRAVELY TEAR DOWN
MONUMENTS TO ALL GENERALS OF THE
CONFEDERACY.
ONE PROBLEM.
THESE ANTIHISTORY BUFF DEFACING
OTHER MONUMENTS OF PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY WORK FOR THE
ABOLITIONIST MOVEMENT, NOW...
AS DRAMATIC AS IT APPEARS AT
TIMES IS A COMPLETE DIVERSION.
THE NEW BOLSHEVIK HOPE YOU WILL
BE SO RIVETED BY WHATEVER PIXIE
PIXIE DUST IS THROWN IN THE AIR
THAT YOUR PARTY IS ABOUT TO NOMI
SOMEONE WHO STRUGGLES WITH THAT
WHOLE SUBJECT VERB DIRECT OBJECT
THING.
>> LOOK, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I THINK IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE SOMEHOW PUT THAT BACK
ON.
>> Laura: BEYOND THE VERBAL
AND COGNITIVE MISCUES, HE IS
JUST A WASHINGTON DINOSAUR THAT
ROAMED THE SWAMP FOR 40 YEARS OR
SO AND YET, FAILED TO MAKE ANY
MEANINGFUL STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO
OUR SUPPOSEDLY ALMOST
IRREDEEMABLY CORRUPT SYSTEM.
SO WHY DIDN’T OBAMA AND BIDEN DO
BIG, MEANINGFUL INITIATIVES ON
THE ISSUES OF POLICING?
AFTER TRAYVON MARTIN AND MICHAEL
BROWN, THEY COULD HAVE RALLIED
CONGRESS, INSTEAD, THEY TOSSED
OUT CRIMES TO SATISFY THEIR
ANGRY ACTIVIST.
NOW OBAMA IS A SMART GUY.
IN HIS HEART OF HEARTS, HE HAS
TO KNOW HIS OWN RECORD FOR A
POLICY ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR
INNER-CITY AMERICA IS KIND OF A
SCAM.
BUT STILL, HE’S MAKING A GUEST
APPEARANCE, I SAW, TO SELL THE
BIDEN ALLUSION NEXT WEEK AT A
VIRTUAL FUND-RAISER.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE A DONATION, BY
THE WAY TO ATTEND, SO WATCH OUT.
THIS WILL BE HYPED BY THE MEDIA
AS IF RETURNED TO NAZARETH BUT
NEWS FLASH FROM I HATE TO
BREAK IT TO YOU, OBAMA WON’T
BE PRESIDENT AGAIN.
AND WITH ALL THE CHALLENGES
BEFORE US, WE NEED TO KIND OF
KNOW WHO EXACTLY WILL BEHIND
THAT BIDEN MOVING ALL THE LEVERS
LEVERS.
BIDEN CAN BE THE UNDERSTUDY TO
THE GUY WHO WAS HIS FURRY EARS.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU DON’T
HAVE A BETTER ECONOMIC RECORD
THAN TRUMP AND YOU ARE RUNNING
AGAINST TRUMP FOR A BETTER
RECORD ON RACE FOR THAT MATTER?
>> JUNE 18TH IS THE OLDEST
CELEBRATION OF THE END OF
SLAVERY IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT IS TIME WE ELEVATE THIS.
JULY 4, 1976, NOT EVERYBODY WAS
FREE AND CELEBRATING
INDEPENDENCE DAY.
SO HERE IS OUR DAY.
AND IF YOU LOVE US, IT WILL BE
YOUR DAY TOO.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, JUNE 13TH
IF THEY WANT THAT TO BE A
HOLIDAY, OKAY, FINE.
BUT PAY NO ATTENTION TO THE
UNTOLD DAMAGE THAT NORTH -- THE
DRACONIAN LOCKDOWN RULES ARE
STILL DOING TO BUSINESSES AND
FAMILIES, ESPECIALLY MINORITY
AND IMMIGRANT OWNED.
YET HE THINKS HE CAN WIPE AWAY
ALL OF THAT WITH SYMBOLS AND
CELEBRITIES?
IT IS MORE DISTRACTION.
NOW THE NEXT TRICK IS TO LAUNCH
A DESPERATE CAMPAIGN TO CAST
PRESIDENT TRUMP THOUGH AS A
VILLAIN WHO THREATENS US ALL.
THEY DON’T LIKE HIM AS A PERSON
SO WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO IS DENY
HE’S DONE ANYTHING AT ALL GOOD
FOR AMERICA, AND OF COURSE THEY
NEED TO CALL HIM RACIST WITH
ZERO EVIDENCE.
HERE IS CONGRESSMAN JIM CLYBURN
WITH BRET BAIER EARLIER TONIGHT.
>> WHAT ABOUT FIRST STEP ACT OR
OPPORTUNITY ZONES?
>> HIS SON-IN-LAW CAME UP AND
WORKED FOR PEOPLE TO GET THE
BILL DONE, AND THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED IT, BUT DON’T TELL ME --
>> THE ADMINISTRATION DID IT.
IT WASN’T THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> I’M NOT TRYING TO ARGUE WITH
YOU BUT YOU CAN WORK IF YOU WANT
TO.
>> YOU ARE NOT GIVING TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION FOR ANYTHING THAT
TIM SCOTT SAID HE SHOULD GET
CREDIT FOR IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I’M NOT.
BECAUSE HE DOESN’T DESERVE IT.
>> Laura: I MEAN, FIRST OF ALL
BRET BAIER WASN’T TRYING TO PICK
A FIGHT WITH HIM.
HE’S DOING THIS THING CALLED
ASKING A FOLLOW-UP QUESTION, BUT
AGAIN, PAY NO ATTENTION TO
TRUMP’S ACTUAL, THE OUTCOME.
JUST IGNORE IT ALL.
INSTEAD, STICK WITH THIS TWISTED
FANTASY THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
REALLY IN HIS HEART OF HEARTS
WANTS TO WORK AGAINST PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
>> SOME DEMOCRATS GO AS FAR AS
TO CALL THE PRESIDENT RACIST.
CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE?
>> IT IS A SAD STATE OF A PEAK
AFFAIRS BUT ALWAYS THE WAY THE
DEMOCRATS PLAY POLITICS AGAINST
REPUBLICANS OF REESE’S AND RICH.
THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS IT IS
ABOUT RESULTS PURITY WAS ELECTED
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING REAL AND I GET NOT
JUST GET LIED TO ABOUT
POLITICIANS.
>> Laura: YOU CAN TELL TODAY
AND WATCHING PRESIDENT TRUMP HE
WAS EXTREMELY MOVED BY MEETING
WITH THE FAMILIES OF MEN KILLED
BY THE POLICE.
>> YOUR LOVED ONES WILL NOT HAVE
DIED IN VAIN.
WHERE WE ARE ONE NATION, WE
GRIEVE TOGETHER AND WE HEALED
TOGETHER.
I CAN NEVER IMAGINE YOUR PAIN
WHERE THE DEPTH OF YOUR ANGUISH,
BUT I CAN PROMISE TO FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE, FOR ALL OF OUR PEOPLE.
>> AND SOME OF THE FAMILIES
SEEMED MOVED AS WELL.
>> IT WAS VERY EMOTIONAL
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE CONFERENCE.
HE WAS VERY COMPASSIONATE AND
ALL FAMILIES, NOT JUST ONE
FAMILY BUT ALL FAMILIES.
I CAN SAY HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP,
HE LISTENED AND HE ADDRESSED
EACH AND EVERY FAMILY
ACCORDINGLY.
>> Laura: NOW, THE REST OF THE
MEDIA, THEY WON’T DWELL ON THAT,
OKAY?
IT DOES NOT FIT THEIR NARRATIVE.
IT WAS REALLY GOOD FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO MEET WITH
THOSE FAMILIES.
BY THE WAY, NO CAMERAS IN THE
ROOM.
JUST A CHANCE TO LISTEN TO THEM.
HEAR THEM, HEAR THEIR VIEWS AND
THE BEST PATH FORWARD TO.
I THINK WE SOMETIMES FORGET IN
THE BITTERNESS OF TODAY’S
POLITICS AND I’M SURE I’M GUILTY
HERE THAT WE ARE ALL HUMAN.
SOMETIMES WE SMILE, SOMETIMES WE
WEEP, SOMETIMES WE CELEBRATE,
SOMETIMES WE GRIEVE, THOSE
FAMILIES ARE GRIEVING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD BE JUDGED
BY HIS COMMITMENT AND HIS
ACTIONS AND HIS RESULTS THAT HE
IS DELIVERING TO ALL AMERICANS,
ESPECIALLY THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED.
WHILE HE REALIZED THERE ARE SOME
THAT JUST DON’T LIKE HIS BRASH
STYLE OR SOMETIMES TOUGH
RESPONSE TO CRITICS ON TWITTER,
DON’T LET THOSE TITLE ISSUES
DISTRACT YOU EITHER.
IT IS COMPLETELY A WASTE OF
TIME.
THIS MAN HAS RISKED EVERYTHING
TO FIGHT FOR AMERICAN WORKERS
WHILE BIDEN HAS BASICALLY
CARRIED WATER FOR CHINA AND ITS
BUDDIES, THE OPEN BORDERS CRAFT.
AND BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE THE ECONOMY
WORK FOR THE AVERAGE AMERICAN.
HE HAS AND WILL AGAIN WHILE
BIDEN SIMPLY WILL DO WHATEVER
THE LEFT WANTS.
HE CAN’T CONTROL AOC OR
ILHAN OMAR OR ANY OF THE OTHER
RADICALS.
HE WON’T EVEN TRY.
AND FINALLY, TRUMP HAD THE
REALISTIC UNDERSTANDING OF CHINA
AND THE E.U. WHILE THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT IS LUDICROUSLY
NAIVE ABOUT BOTH.
HOW HARD IS IT TO IMAGINE BIDEN
DOING HIS OWN VERSION OF OBAMA’S
POST-BUSH 2009 APOLOGY TOUR?
AND WHILE JOE WAS BUSY
APOLOGIZING, CHINA AND THE E.U.
WILL CLEAN HIS AND OUR CLOCK.
NOW JUST LIKE DOROTHY AND
FRIENDS COME AMERICANS WILL BE
DISAPPOINTED IF IT BECOMES
APPARENT THAT BIDEN BEHIND THAT